what what are you like if you're a if
you're a tech guy now what are you
what's the next what's left yeah what is
the last what is left I really don't
know it's just like apps for I think
once they legalized prostitution
that's comment that'll be good that'll
be coming there will be that'll become
old right I want to go on a GrubHub and
just pick a dick yeah right and then
just go you know I think that's gonna be
the next thing that'll be the next they
haven't already ready they're just
waiting for like a law to get passed and
then they just drop the hammer of the
Rogan made a good point he's like
there's all these in sells legalized
prostitution right just legalize
prostitution cut out the shootings
eventually eventually what I think
you'll start to see is you will start to
see like the there's all these weird
creepy like Elon Musk owns a bunch of
these companies I think one is called
neural link where it's literally about
just you know implanting like it's
merging biology with AI it's essentially
merging it's like Elon Musk II said we
gotta merge with technology so that AI
doesn't destroy us we have to merge with
it or they're gonna destroy us because
we've already opened a can of worms and
it is what it is and as soon as a I can
just read they can read every book
that's ever been written an instant
they're gonna be smarter than us they'll
be smarter than Jordan Peterson they'll
be smarter than everybody mm-hmm and
then they're gonna come and they're
gonna look at us like bugs and they'll
probably get rid o just get rid of us if
we stand in their way see La Mosque is
like what we have to do is merge with
them right and the government's been
studying all these things like the Penta
is this thing called DARPA which is the
defense I don't know ever gonna say it
right but it's like the defense agency
read the defense agency Research
Projects administration or something of
that and they study weapon systems of
the future and they're the book on it
was written by Andy Jacobsen who's uh
she just went on Rogan and I know we're
a little because her son his friends
with my friend's son and I tried to get
her on my show but she's too busy for
that
and she's got a she talks like a
stripper and she's like wow
I heard Joe Joe it's talking about
mommies actually in area 51 it's really
a way it's really wet and it's wet
because and it's like you she's a phone
sex operator with a brain of OHS for
UFOs so she wrote a book and she was
basically like listen these guys are 20
years ahead all the technology that we
have 20 years ago they had that so they
had some version of it right and that
they have things that are so 20 years
from now is terrifying and she said some
of the things that they're working on
are these neural links neural interface
programs where you can order drone
strikes with your head because it's too
much time to order them with your finger
because there's a lot of deliberation
right doesn't it seem like that yeah
when we're just bomb and weddings and
poor kids playing soccer and Pakistan
it's it's apparently too hard to level
villages right so what we need to do is
have basically some chip in someone's
head so they could just think about a
drone strike and then it'll just start
to light the world on fire so that's
that's on its way me and Ben were
watching our drone strikes the other day
[Laughter]
it's important by the way it's important
if you if you feeling patriotic yeah at
any point go and watch a drone struck go
watch a death machine
fly across the air and kill probably an
innocent child yeah and really get an
idea what and the idea that like and by
the way these people have never even
seen this technology it would be the
equivalent of us having UFOs come here
and just vaporize right right they're
out there and would you end and you
start to realize that like Isis was
never a threat all of the idea that
these people are threats is a complete
[ __ ] lie these people are in caves
and want them we fund them we make them
if false anyway they're improv team yes
and yeah that's what we do that's
exactly what we do yeah okay so pretend
let's say you were gonna attack a
country which it may be you do it with
this weapon this is a prop it's old Bill
Hicks joke you know you give the guy you
know you give it's like that Jack
Palance in the movie shame right right
you give the guy a gun and you're like
look at ya look at him he had a gun yeah
but it's like you watch those drone
strikes you say to yourself it's hard to
take any politician seriously that gets
on TV and starts talking about Isis or
any of these you could just vaporize and
you only have to get to that level which
is the most depressing part because they
all start off like in this time or they
gone Rogan they sound like oh man like
grassroots like yeah it's gonna be
they're gonna they're like real it's a
real person yeah can I keep going a year
goes by the campaign then they're
talking about all the [ __ ] that yeah you
got bit yeah well yeah well what I think
the reality is that one of the two
things is a show right
so it's either Obama coming out before
he gets into office saying I think that
we've gone a little too far in Iraq
right which is what needed to happen
nobody would have won if a guy was like
listen the problem is we need more at
that point the country was like wait
wait hold on wait a minute you needed a
guy who was cerebral and articulate to
go out there go yeah there's limits to
what the American military could do so
then what they did was just quietly
drone strike people quietly George liked
people and then he you know went on
Ellen and danced so all these idiot blue
checkmarks out here were like yeah scran
they were like oh he's great and and and
and so you say to yourself you're like
well which is the real guy and then it's
more complicated than that I'm sure and
I'm sure it's not as easy and I'm sure
when you get in there the CIA all these
people cuz I know because I've read
books and I've had people on the show
they start telling you all these things
that you need to do because we're in
where we're in because they they they
basically go in there and go the
presidential daily briefing the threat
assessment which Trump by the way was
like I don't need it
Thanks keep moving but that is really to
just go in there and terrify right who's
ever the president they just terrifying
yeah and they go we heard that a guy was
gonna blow up the Sears Tower just
because some raving lunatic
in Beirut is running around talking
nonsense and they presented to the
president like it's an actionable piece
of information right well they're like
well any day now that's so you just
better authorize whatever the [ __ ] we
have to do and and and this is why it's
like it's hard to take anybody [ __ ]
seriously when they go out there any of
these politicians and they start talking
about you know the great threats and
da-da-da-da-da and yeah it's like you
know it's like a I feel like now it's
like a the country's like a like a madla
like they fill in the blanks for what
they know we want to hear now cuz
they're hip enough to it cuz it's just
like oh the people okay now I know what
they want to hear I'm not gonna come off
all right and dumb like at the 8th yeah
and he's like just out of touch right
I'm gonna say what they want to hear but
then when I'm in I'll just do what the
[ __ ] they tell me to do cuz that's what
we did all the threats are internal yeah
let's be honest yeah it's the the opium
I mean the the opioid epidemic you have
you know yeah we focus on any of that
when I focusing on that we have we have
people eating food with plastic in it
pretty much like we have we have people
turning on the faucet and like purple
water's coming out brown water [ __ ]
colored waters coming out you know we
have a health care system where I mean I
love this tweet where the guy goes they
go
isn't this great Home Depot they tweet
outs of a Home Depot they go
isn't it great is they didn't know if
this his health care company would cover
a walker for this three-year-old so Home
Depot made him one Home Depot when got
some scraps from the parking lot and
made a walker for this three-year-old
cuz his parents talked to the health
care company and health care companies
like well I don't know we gotta figure
this out but why don't you carry him so